the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi our lecture today if we're looking at
this from an analytical point of view
should be called maxima and minima and
if we're looking at it from the
geometric point of view high points and
low points and actually whichever point
of view we're looking at it from it's a
very nice application of much of the
theory that we have learned up until now
so without further ado let's talk a
little bit about what we mean by high
points low points maxima or minima which
is as I say I've called the lecture
today now as is always the case we
usually have to have some sort of a
fundamental result from which all of our
other results follow and in this context
what I call the fundamental theorem for
a study of maxima minima is the
following suppose that f of C is at
least as great as f of X for all X in a
delta neighborhood of C in other words
we have some open interval of width
Delta surrounding C and that for all X
in that neighborhood F of C is at least
as great as f of X or equivalently it
might be that F of C is less than or
equal to f of X for all X in this
neighborhood and suppose also that F
prime of C exists then the theorem says
F prime of C in this case must be 0 and
whereas this can be proven analytically
again the analytical proof is motivated
by what's happening geometrically and
the geometric demonstration is
particularly easy to visualize in this
particular case let me run the risk of
drawing this fairly freehand here see
what we're saying is this suppose you
have at the point C comma F of C on this
particular curve suppose that this
particular curve the derivative exists
and is positive see that's the way I've
drawn this in other words notice that in
the neighborhood of the point C here for
example the derivative here is positive
the curve is always rising now what
we're saying over here is that if you
look at this particular picture of
serve that FC will not exceed f of X for
all X in this neighborhood in fact I
think you can see just by looking at
this picture that as x increases f of X
increases in other words in terms of
this picture if X is less than C f of X
is less than F of C and if X is greater
than C f of X is greater than f of C in
other words what we're saying is if the
derivative is positive it means that the
curve is always rising and hence the
point in the middle of that neighborhood
cannot be the highest point in that
neighborhood north for example can it be
the lowest point in fact a similar
argument holds if we want to illustrate
that F of C is less than or equal to f
of X in this particular neighborhood and
by the way again observe what we're
saying this is rather crucial over here
first of all we're talking about a
sufficiently small neighborhood of C
what I mean by that is something like
this you see and by the way this could
cause a little bit of a problem if
you're not careful with your language
see if we drew a picture like this and
you say to somebody
where are the high low points on this I
think it's quite natural that a person
would say well this is the high point
I'll call that H and this is the low
point I'll call that L and he might tend
to forget about this point here because
even though it's fairly high it's not
nearly as high as this point what I'd
like you to see however is that our
definition our definition talks about
what in a neighborhood of the given
point you see what we're saying here is
that if we pick a particular
neighborhood and appropriately chosen
neighborhood surrounding C then what is
true is that at the value of X
corresponding to C F of C is the highest
point in a suitable neighborhood of C in
other words if you knew that for some
reason or other you had to be working in
this
but here you could say well in the
domain in which I'm interested in this
is a high point and this is why we talk
about local or relative Maxima or minima
as opposed or in addition to absolute
maxima and minima in fact you see this
happens quite frequently in practice
suppose you were doing an experiment and
you really wanted to produce the largest
possible value of y well you see utopian
Li you would like to pick X out here
someplace
but suppose because of some constraint
in the laboratory the largest value of x
that you could choose might be over here
and then you see what the equivalent
problem would be and this is where the
domain of the function has such a
powerful meaning in terms of practical
applications what you're saying is look
at if the domain of my function is
limited to this interval over here then
this particular point as far as I'm
concerned is the highest point you see
in other words then notice that the
labeling n sub Delta of C indicates that
you're talking locally rather than
globally in a neighborhood of C okay and
this is the important issue here now the
hardest part about this particular
result as I see it is not understanding
the result as much as it is of reading
more into the result than what's really
there and so I have a few cautions for
you the three Commandments they turn out
to be the first is beware of false
converses and before you can be beware
of false converses you have to know what
a converse is roughly speaking a
converse applies only to an if-then type
of statement and you get the converse of
a given statement by interchanging the
clauses that follow the if and event and
the reason had to beware is that a true
statement can have a false converse for
example consider the following true
statement if a person is listening to me
lecture now then he is alive
hopefully a true statement okay if we
now interchange the clauses to form the
converse it says if a person is alive
then he is listening to me
a tragically false statement okay but
notice the difference between inverting
the clauses of an if-then statement and
the idea is this
notice that our theorem says if F prime
exists C then R if there is a local
maximum or a local minimum f prime of C
is 0 it does not say that if F prime of
C is 0 we have a local maximum or a
local minimum perhaps the easiest way to
see that is in terms of an example
that's the nicest thing to show how a
converse is false to prove that
something is true you can't do it just
by showing it's true in certain cases
but the show that something is not true
all you have to do is Exhibit one
example in which the result is false
that's enough to prove that it can't
always be true for example in this
particular diagram notice that in the
curve y equals f of X which I've drawn
here the curve at the point C comma F of
C has a horizontal tangent in other
words f prime of C is 0 here but notice
that in any neighborhood that surrounds
C in any open interval that's around C
notice that if X is less than C f of X
will be less than F of C and if X is
greater than C f of X will be greater
than F of C in other words notice that
except for the stationary value at which
we have a horizontal tangent the graph
is always rising in any neighborhood of
C okay that's the first point I want you
to see the second point says beware if F
prime of C doesn't exist see all our
theorem said is look at if you have a
relative high point a relative low point
relative Max or relative men and X equal
C and if F prime of C exists if F prime
of C exists then F prime of C is 0 but
who said that F prime of C has to exist
again let's look in terms of an example
if we let f of X equal the absolute
value of X recall from our previous
assignments and the like that the
derivative of f of X in this case does
not exist when x is 0 in other words F
prime of 0
doesn't exist and why is that well
notice that the graph of y equals the
absolute value of x is the straight line
y equals x if X is non-negative and the
straight line y equals minus X if X is
negative in other words f prime of X is
1 if X is positive it's minus 1 if X is
negative and hence the jump
discontinuity in the derivative at 0 but
you see the point is this if you look at
our graph do we have a low point at x
equals 0 in other words is this the
lowest point in a neighborhood of the of
0 and the answer is yes in fact it's an
absolute low point meaning that no
matter where you go no point on our
graph can be less or lower than this
particular point here but that's
irrelevant the point is what if we
looked for a place where F prime of C
was 0 in this example we wouldn't find
one that would not mean that there
wasn't a low point what happened was
what the low point snuck in at a place
where the derivative did not exist and
again you have to be careful all I said
was what be where of points for which F
prime of C does not exist it does not
mean that each point where F prime of C
does not exist that you're going to have
a high or a low point for example
remember that the derivative not
existing loosely speaking means what
that is a sharp corner to the curve what
I'm thinking of is something like this
let's take a curve that's always rising
say something like this now let's
suppose we put a sharp corner in here
but in such a way that the curve still
continues to always rise say like this
now you see at this particular value of
C F prime of C
doesn't exist and I think you can see
intuitively what's happening here you
the slope approaches one value as you
approach C from the left and another
value if you approach C from the right
now even though F prime of C doesn't
exist at this point notice that this
point is neither a high nor a low point
meaning that all points what to the left
of this point are below it and all
points to the right of this point are
above it so again what B where when F
prime of C equals zero but don't jump to
any false conclusions and the third
caution is an extremely important one in
fact for the first time from a practical
point of view we are going to probably
see analytically what is the difference
between an open interval and a closed
interval see suppose I have the function
f of X equals x squared but the domain
of F is now the open interval from 2 to
3 in other words F the inputs of the f
machine are restricted to all those
numbers which are greater than 2 but
less than 3 now let's take a look here
let's first of all see where f prime of
x is 0
first of all f prime of X is 2x and that
equals 0 if and only if x equals 0 now
here's where the domain is very
important is x equals 0
in our domain the answer is no X equals
0 is lying I don't mean that domain is
restricted to be the open interval from
2 to 3 therefore as far as our function
f is concerned and remember way back in
one of our early it was a lecture was in
our supplementary notes we pointed out
that when you define a function you need
not only the rule but you must specify
the domain remember two functions we
equal not only if they were the same
rule but they had to be defined on the
same domain so f here is defined on a
domain from 2 to 3 and on that
particular domain of definition there is
no place where the derivative is 0 by
the same token since the derivative is a
polynomial and all polynomials are
differentiable and all differentiable
functions are continuous this certainly
will be
no places where F prime of X doesn't
exist in other words F primer exists for
all X in the domain of F in other words
here is a particular example in which a
particular function on its domain of
definition does not have any high or low
points on it and I'll illustrate that
graphically in a few moments I simply
wanted to put this on the board first to
put it into sharp contrast with what
we're going to say next you see if we're
not careful in fact the next problem
looks exactly the same as the problem
that we just solved namely what we want
to do now is investigate the function f
of X equals x squared but we want the
domain of F now to be what the closed
interval from 2 to 3 in other words the
only difference between this problem and
the problem that we just solved is that
now we want the endpoints included all
right now there's no sense repeating the
part that we did before first of all
will F time of X equals 0 in the domain
of definition as we saw before
no is f prime nonexistent anyplace
in the interval no it's differentiable
to smooth polynomial curve as there is
no now here's where we come to two very
important points that hopefully will
clarify certain conventions that were
made in the textbook in our section of
Hui there was a little result that may
have seemed a little bit obscure it said
what that a continuous function defined
on a closed interval must take on its
maximum and minimum values someplace on
that closed interval you see all we've
proven over here is what that if f has a
max or a min what we've proven is what
it does not occur it does not occur in
the open interval from A to B see well
look at if it has if the high and low
points have to occur someplace on the
closed interval and they can't appear as
we've seen in the open interval where
must they occur well if they can't be
inside and they have to be on the
interval it must be that they take place
at the endpoints now you see what you
see let's go back without referring back
to another board remember we wrote down
when we're talking about high and low
points that we talked about X being in a
delta neighborhood of C it meant what
that you could surround C by some
bandwidth Delta
you see and notice that our definition
in the textbook of a neighborhood was
always an open interval and the reason
that the definition is given to be open
is that notice that what the definition
now says is what you know what's going
on on either side of si si we know
what's going on in either side of C
notice that in the case where you have a
closed interval by definition of a
closed interval notice that what we know
what's happening as we come in on a from
the right and we know what's happening
to B as we come in on it from the left
but allegedly meaning that since the
function is only defined on the closed
interval from A to B we don't know
what's happening before a and we don't
know what's happening before B in other
words this is why the test for F prime
of C equaling zero applies only all need
to see being in the interior in other
words in an open interval so in other
words then you see if a function happens
to be continuous on a closed interval
and it doesn't have any high-low points
in the interior of the interval then it
must have its high-low points where it
must be at the endpoints and to show you
quite simply what was going on in this
particular problem notice that if we
graph f of x equals x squared and look
at this say first of all on the closed
interval from 2 to 3 what we're saying
is look at any point in which we look at
the neighborhood that isn't 2 or 3 the
curve is rising on one side of the point
and in other words the curve is rising
on both sides of the point so that if
you're to the left of the point the
height will be less than the point
you're interested in if you're to the
right of it the height will exceed the
point that you're interested in but
notice that at the endpoints themselves
you do have what in this case not a
relative high or low but actually an
absolute high or low in other words the
point 2 comma 4 C what is the end point
here the end point here is one endpoint
is for the other endpoint going up on
the Y Direction here is 9 what you're
saying is what
four is less than nine every value of x
squared between two and three falls
between four and nine and what you're
saying is what that the lowest point
occurs when access to the highest point
occurs when y is three the interesting
point to note is that if you now look at
the open interval and exclude the
endpoints you cannot get a lowest point
or a highest point namely notice that if
you allow yourself to get as close to
two as you want without ever getting
there
it means you could have done what moves
closer to two in other words if X is
greater than two you can pick another
value that's one between x and two
there's a space there in other words
what you're saying is that no matter how
low you get here as long as you're not
exactly a two you can find the point
that's lower and the same way as you
move out this way as you move closer and
closer to this point if you exclude this
point itself no matter where you stop
you could have always found the point
that was a little bit higher and again
you have to be where when I say check
the endpoints of a closed interval it
does not mean that the endpoints will
give you high or low points for example
look at the following curve it looks
something like this it's continuous it's
defined on the closed interval from A to
B notice that at a we do not get an
absolute maximum in fact what all of
these points on the curve are higher
than what's happening here same thing
happens what all of these points are
lower than what the height is
corresponding to x equals a and the
similar way this is what happens at B
you see with the endpoints obviously
since you can't see what's happening
before this will be either the highest
point or the lowest point near here
depending on how the curve the slope but
all we're saying is what in terms of
absolute high values and absolute low
values meaning the highest possible
points and the lowest possible points we
must always check the endpoints but we
can't be positive that the endpoints are
going to be chosen in fact let's
summarize and I'm going to summarize
again at the end of the lecture but the
idea resists if f of X is continuous on
the closed and the
from A to B and here's the keyword to
find candidates you know the Oh cliche
about many are called but few were
chosen in this case few are called and
even fewer are chosen namely what we're
saying is looking when we're looking for
high-low points the candidates are what
those points for which the derivative is
zero see we can check those out because
those are possibilities those points for
which the derivative fails to exist we
can check those out because their
possibilities and the endpoints okay
namely if the function is continuous we
checked the endpoints by the way if the
function is not continuous then there is
no need to check what that's for this
way if you're on an open interval
there's no need to check the endpoints
because there aren't any now there was
notice that I'm talking about what that
the function f is not only continuous
but on a closed interval so there is to
this in other words these are all the
possible candidates now you see the
bigger question is how do you use this
and I thought that I would make up a
makeshift exercise one that's rather
easy to do with the blackboard from
deeper exercises for more quantitative
results we have several exercises in the
learning exercises several exercises
worked out illustratively
in the textbook but let's pick a
particularly straightforward example
let's suppose that what I want to do is
construct a cylinder this is a
cross-sectional view of a cylinder
X represents the radius of the base and
Y represents the height this is a right
circular cylinder I'm given a constraint
namely I'm told that for some reason or
other and I don't know why anybody would
ever want to impose this condition other
than the fact that we want some
condition imposed here to see what's
happening I'm told that I want the sum
of the radius of the base and the
altitude to be exactly 30 in other words
if the radius of the base is going to be
6 inches I want the altitude to be 24
inches that's a constraint and by the
way I'll come back to this later also
notice how you're almost begging a
related rates relationship here
are an implicit relationship with x and
y are not independent but I've now put a
constraint on here any rate the question
is how shall I use up my 30 inches say
if I want to make the volume of the
resulting cylinder as large as possible
and notice how we work this thing we say
well the volume is equal to PI x squared
Y in this particular case it's easy to
see explicitly that Y is equal to 30
minus X it's also easy to see physically
that X must be more than zero you can't
have a negative radius of the base it
must be less than 30 because if you used
up more than 30 inches in the radius of
your base how can the radius of the base
plus the altitude add up to exactly 30
because physically the constraint is
that the altitude can't be negative it's
certainly a positive value so our
analytic relationship is what that V
equals PI x squared Y which can be
written as PI x squared times 30 minus X
which in turn can be written as the
polynomial 30 PI x squared minus PI X
cubed where X is the open interval are
defined on the open interval from 0 to
30 now how do I proceed what was my test
for membership I I have three ways of
checking out where high-low points will
occur or max min points in this case
since notice that this function does not
require a graph to understand it I first
check out to see where the derivative is
zero well the derivative is simply 60 PI
X minus 3 PI x squared if I set this
thing equal to 0 I find upon factoring
that either X must be 0 or X must be 20
I can immediately exclude x equals 0
because you see notice that my function
V had its domain of definition on the
open interval from 0 to 30 x equals 0 is
not in the open interval from 0 to 30
consequently within rule this thing out
and what we discover is that x equals 20
so x equals 20 is the only possible
candidate that we have and by the way
since the sum of x and y must be 20 if x
was 20 y must be 10 so the only
candidate that we have by setting the
derivatives equal to zero is that X
should be 20 and Y should be 10 we do
not get any candidates in the sense of
where the derivative doesn't exist
because if you look at 60 PI X minus 3
PI x squared this certainly exists for
all values of X and finally we have no
endpoints to check because again we add
our function V is defined on an open
interval by the way if I try to draw
this somewhat to scale a very
interesting result turns up which may
show the power of analytical methods
versus more intuitive types of methods
you see what we showed here was what
without going into the details that they
get the largest volume cylinder X should
be 20 in other words the radius of your
base should be 20 and the altitude
should be 10 let's take a look at that
drawn roughly to scale the raise of the
base here is 20 and the altitude is 10
by the way that means that the cross
section will be 1 a rectangle whose
height is 10 and whose base is 40 now
you know intuitively I think it's easy
to see that for a rectangle for a given
perimeter the largest possible area
rectangle is the one which hat which is
a square well we're not even trying to
prove that let's go to this thing here
instead of using up to 20 and the 10
let's draw a second rectangle or a
second cross-section of a cylinder where
the radius is 15 and the height is 15
notice that this still satisfies the
fact that the sum of the radius and the
altitude are 30 now look at this if we
compute the area of this particular
rectangle 40 times 10 its 400 on the
other hand the volume is what pi times
20 squared the radius of the base
squared times the height which is 10 and
that yields a result of 4000 PI on the
other hand if we look at our second
rectangle it's area is 450 but it's
volume is what it's pi times 15 squared
times 15 which is 3,300
seventy-five pi the interesting result
here is what the area of this rectangle
is greater than the area of this
rectangle fact the area of a the second
rectangle is 450 the area of the first
rectangle was only 400 but notice that
when you revolve this thing to form the
cylinder the smaller cross-sectional
area the smaller cross-sectional area
generates the larger volume and the
reason of course for that is that the
relationship and our variables was not
linear in other words notice that when X
is large a relatively small change in X
produces a large change in x squared in
other words a relatively small value in
X can offset a relatively large value or
increase in Y and this is kind of
interesting because try to figure out
intuitively how you would figure out
where these stop compensating for one
another where is it turned out that
finally you've taken so much away from X
that even though you square it it can't
compensate the change in Y
how would you intuitively pick off where
the high-low points that occur in a
problem like this and all I want you to
see is again the beautiful gentle
balance between intuitive calculus and
rigorous calculus that we don't throw
away our intuition but notice how in
many cases where our intuition fails us
the analytic recipes come to our rescue
but enough said about that
let me now again highlight the
difference or the relationship between
functions and graphs namely in all of
this discussion that we've done on this
particular board we're talking about
what V being a function of X we do not
have to visualize this thing pictorially
but if we wish what we can say is let's
graph V as a function of X and you see
going back to the material of last time
and notice you see how interrelated
these things are notice how curve
plotting ties in very nicely with
derivatives and the like all we're
saying is what given this relationship
which is how V is related to X we can
form the first derivative we can form
the
and derivative we can look to see where
the first derivative is zero we can look
to see where the second derivative is
zero I leave these details to you
because after the homework assignment
you did last time these should be fairly
trivial exercises to do but the idea is
if you now utilize all of this
information you find that if you plot V
versus X you get a graph something like
this by the way again notice that we
were not talking about just V being a
function of X the domain of V was
restricted to be the open interval from
0 to 30 and this is a very crucial thing
to keep in mind you can get into a whole
bunch of trouble if you start looking to
see what happens out here for example
you say hey this curve is always going
to keep going up won't this be greater
than this maximum value over here
eventually the answer is yes it will be
but what does it mean to say that X is
negative X was the radius of our base so
in other words what we should really say
here is what that the function that
we're talking about is not this whole
curve
yikes that wasn't a very good job of
drawing but rather what just this
portion of the curve defined on the open
interval from 0 to 30 by the way let me
point out something else you recall in
an earlier lecture we talked about
related rates we had an assignment
without a lecture where you've solved
some problems using related rates let me
show you how related rates play a very
important computational role in dealing
with max-min problems you know in this
particular problem we had that V equals
PI x squared Y where Y happened to be a
particular function of X in fact
implicitly it was given by the fact that
X plus y happened to equal 30 now let's
keep track of something here
in this particular problem notice that
it was very easy to change this implicit
relationship to an explicit one it was
also easy once you expressed Y
explicitly in terms of X that when you
want to substitute into here it was a
very easy computational job to carry out
the operations but supposed to happen to
be cube roots in here or all sorts of
nasty
things whatever they might be and
suppose instead of X plus y equals 30
you had our old friend something like X
to the eighth plus X to the sixth Y
squared plus y to the sixth equals three
how would you solve for y explicitly in
terms of X there and the point that I'd
like you to see is that we can solve
this problem very nicely without having
to resort to explicitly replacing Y as a
function of X namely implicitly assuming
that Y is a differentiable function of X
we can differentiate this thing as a
product DV DX would be what the
derivative of the first factor which is
2 pi x times the second plus the first
factor which is PI x squared times the
derivative of Y with respect to X ok
that's DV DX on the other hand from this
relationship here we can conclude by
differentiating implicitly that 1 + dy
DX is 0 and therefore dy DX is minus 1
and putting that value for dy DX in here
we wind up with this explicit
relationship and we can now see that the
V DX is 0 if and only if just by solving
this thing setting equal to 0 x equals
2y by the way that's exactly what
happened in our problem you'll notice
that X turned out to be 20 and Y turned
out to be 10 you see again x and y are
related you can't say gee couldn't X be
60 and Y be 30 answer no because the
constraint is that X plus y must be 30
well look I don't want us to get too
wrapped up on the idea of computational
differences now what I do want to do is
review basic result and in fact let me
come over here I hope this doesn't spoil
you I'd like to come back to the board
and actually since I've got this all
written down
let's close on this particular result
again to find the high-low points of a
function f of X we first of all check
out where F prime of C is 0 for
candidates we check out where F prime of
C fails to exist and if it's a closed
interval we check the endpoints this is
the
and ISM behind what we're doing from
that point on as the cliche goes it's
all Engineering's baby it's all
computational know-how at any rate I
think this is enough in terms of
emphasizing the points that we wanted to
make and so until next time goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate